la República democrática del Congo está
de luto nacional tras la muerte de un
centenar de personas en la provincia
oriental de kivu del Norte allí según
las fuerzas armadas de la República
democrática del Congo y la misión de la
ONU en la región el grupo armado m-23 se
enfrentó a elementos de una milicia
local de autodefensa los combates
habrían dejado decenas de civiles
muertos el sábado líderes religiosos se
reunieron en la capital provincial goma
nos comprometemos efectivamente con el
proyecto de paz en kibú del Norte
apoyamos a las autoridades de la
provincia en sus esfuerzos por buscar la
paz y la convivencia pacífica de las
comunidades llamamos a todos los fieles
y a la población en general para que se
impliquen en la promoción de la paz en
el este de la República democrática del
Congo los combates se han reanudado
menos de una semana después de que se
anunciara alto el fuego y los civiles
están en primera línea tengo muchas
preocupaciones Porque no tenemos Paz ni
alegría al ver como matan a nuestros
compatriotas en las ciudades de rutsuru
rugnoni y rugarit este nuevo ciclo de
violencia se produce mientras los
líderes de grupos armados y los
representantes del gobierno están
reunidos en la capital de Kenia nairobi
para encontrar soluciones duraderas a la
situación pero hay un problema
importante Cómo se puede pretender
encontrar una salida a la crisis si el
grupo armado más activo el m-23 está
excluido de las discusiones otra
consecuencia directa del conflicto la
cuestión de los desplazados desde
principios de 2022 al menos 350.000
personas han tenido que abandonar sus
hogares